A spotlight in 3JS is similar to a spotlight in the real world. You shine this
sort of light on something to make it the focus of attention. This emitter is
like a point light in that it has a position. It's also like a directional
light, in that you have to point it somewhere. However, there's one important
addition. Control of the cone of light it forms. The main control in 3JS is the
angle where the spotlight ends. There's also a fall off exponent that's similar
to how specular highlighting works. As you increase this number the spotlight
becomes tighter. More elaborate spotlights are possible. For example, this is
3D Studio Max's spotlight. It uses two angles to control the outer cone, and a
separate inner cone it calls a hot spot. The spotlight can also be circular or
rectangular. There are no rules about what constitutes a spotlight, and with
shader programming, you can create any sort of spotlight you can imagine. I
should also mention, at this point, that you can put any number of lights in a
scene. There's only one ambient light setting, but you can have as many spot,
point, and directional lights as you want. Each light's contribution is added
to the fragment's final color.